-Now, Donald Trump
does not like either of us,
but he might dislike you more
because I tell jokes about him,
but you sue him.
-Well...
-And sometimes --
Sometimes,
you sue him to the point
that he has to give up money,
and he likes that a lot.
-No, but you mocked him
and humiliated him and his hair
on national TV.
I don't know, Seth.
-Yeah. A little of both.
-It's a close call.
-Uh, now,
you have sued him in the past.
You sued Trump University
for fraud.
He swore he would
never settle that.
He was elected president.
He did settle it.
Originally, you guys were
looking into Trump University
because you just wanted him
to take away the name
"university," right?
-Well, we were looking at
for-profit colleges generally,
and there were problems
with for-profit colleges
ripping people off.
Actually, we've sued the Federal
Department of Education
for trying to remove rules
that would protect students
from being ripped off
by for-profit colleges
a couple of weeks ago.
And we were looking
at for-profit colleges,
and there was Trump University
hanging out there,
like, with a neon sign on it
saying "Fraud Here."
And we attempted to negotiate
a settlement. That failed.
And so, in the summer of 2013,
we sued him.
And that's when our relationship
took a turn for the worst.
-Yeah.
He has mentioned you on Twitter
a couple of times...
not very kindly.
Here's one. "Lightweight
A.G. Eric Schneiderman
is perhaps the most incompetent
and least respected A.G.
in the U.S.
He's a total joke."
[ Laughter ]
"Lightweight
@AGSchneiderman..."
He used your Twitter handle
that time.
That's very -- He wanted
to make sure you saw it.
"Just got his ass kicked
by Trump."
And, then, "It's Thursday."
I like, by the way, when
he tells you what day it is.
"It's Thursday.
What brand of eyeliner
is the nation's worst A.G.
wearing today?"
-Yes.
-Now, do you take it as a...
point of pride when someone like
this attacks you on Twitter?
-Well, look,
it was very unusual.
I mean, we sue a lot of people
for fraud.
I'd never seen the sort of
scorched-earth approach
he brought to it.
He set up a website
to attack me,
sued me for $100 million,
filed phony ethics complaints
against me.
The full front page
of his son-in-law's newspaper,
The Observer, was --
-Oh, yes.
-Here you go.
This is Jared Kushner's --
Jared Kushner's newspaper.
And that's you right there.
-That's me with the eyeliner
as the Malcolm McDowell
character
in "A Clockwork Orange."
-"Clockwork Eric."
-So, in retrospect --
I didn't realize this in 2013 --
I got a preview
of the scorched earth
he brought to the campaign
last year,
'cause before there was
Lyin' Ted and Little Marco,
there was Clockwork Eric.
But this is the approach
he brings to litigation
and the approach
he brings to politics.
-Now, no matter what happened
on election night,
you were gonna have Donald Trump
in your life
because all his businesses --
He has so much stuff
in New York.
You're still looking into
his foundation.
You were looking into
his university.
But now you're actually
having to sue Donald Trump
as a person who's representing
the federal government.
Tell me some of the things
that you have had to do
to defend against
Donald Trump's actions already.
-Oh, sure.
Well, in terms of public policy,
we have sued them
over their refusal
to keep toxic pesticides
out of kids' food.
We have sued them
for their efforts
to dismantle
the cost-sharing subsidies
under the Affordable Care Act,
Obamacare,
which is still, as we sit here
tonight, the law of the land.
-Yeah. We'll see how --
We'll see how long.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I think will remain so.
But the Trump administration
won't defend any
of the Obama-era policies.
So, I have intervened and sued,
and other A.G.'s
have intervened and sued.
We are taking up the cause
where --
They won't defend any
of the Obama era's policies
on climate change.
You mentioned the EPA
at the top of the show.
They got a bunch
of climate-change deniers
in charge of the EPA.
So we are now defending
the Clean Power Plan,
other Obama-era initiatives,
and we're suing them
for their failure
to provide protection
for students
who get ripped off by still
existing for-profit colleges.
So we're going after them.
But it's all policy.
It's not about him personally.
It's all on the merits,
but there are a lot of merits
these days, yeah.
-You talk about, you know,
one of the things you're doing
is defending.
You're defending policies
and the legal basis
of those policies.
It seems like
what people want of you,
what a certain amount
of people want of you,
is that your
legal investigation,
your legal work will lead
to some grand impeachment,
that this is one of the things
that people like you need to do.
Is it sort of wishful thinking?
And do Democrats in general
need to step back from this idea
that impeachment is something
that's going to happen
and that impeachment
is something
that's going to come about
by legal means?
-Well, no. I think
you have to separate it out.
Our first job is to protect
the people we represent
from these horrendous
public policies
that pour out of Washington
like a bad-idea toxic volcano.
I mean, every day, there's
some new bad public policy
that would hurt people.
We're going to protect them.
As to misconduct
by the Trump campaign
colluding with Russia
or, you know,
allegations of money laundering
by people around the president,
those are separate
investigations.
Those are going forth.
But I do think it is important
for Democrats to recognize
the there is no substitute
for the hard work at the end of
the day of electing good people.
And we have to go back
and elect good people
from the grassroots up
in order to get this
country back on track.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm...
Let it never be said
that attorney generals
can't have some fun.
I want -- If you could,
real quick, explain to us.
You had an
Operation Wrecking Ball?
-Uh, we did.
-And can you tell us
how you came to the title
Operation Wrecking Ball,
how you came to name it that?
-Yeah, this was an Organized
Crime Task Force investigation
of a gang that was dealing guns
and drugs in upstate New York.
And they apparently
were Miley Cyrus fans.
And their -- The code word
for cocaine was "Miley Cyrus."
So we took a Miley Cyrus song,
called it
Operation Wrecking Ball,
and busted all of them.
-Well, congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
-And thank you
for all your hard work.
Keep it up. And thank you
so much for being here.
-Thank you, Seth.
-Attorney General
Eric Schneiderman, everybody.